all right gel back for Bravo con on the
og panel I heard they made you watch
back the word done clip on the stage
wait thought I've said that so many
times since you have no idea I say it
all the time it's part of my vocabulary
we're done and then we're not done so is
it not hard to watch that stuff back
it's all hard of course it's like
torture but you have to have humor in it
because it's like it's so old already
that in real life I wouldn't even
remember it but of course that's to keep
being brought up to me but that's who I
am and I don't apologize for it I was
mad I said we're done I meant at that
moment that's why you were great for the
show you and Bethenny where do things
stand today actually very good you know
no peace a month what did you think of
her walking away for a second time was
it the right choice oh I don't know I
was I surprised I was surprised no I was
not surprised I I just wasn't surprised
because I think that Bethenny always
knows when the party's over for her and
when she wants to move on she you know
owns it and goes and if she thinks it's
a mistake she'll come back alright so
you want to be surprised if she came
back either for a second would be
surprised because I think she's done but
what do I know you know now the day she
announced she was leaving immediately
people were like bring Jill back Jill's
coming back right I mean I can never
live up to that I can never live up to
the fans wanting me to come back but I
think I'm done I mean I the time is over
for me I had my run and I'm very happy I
did and I have a great man in my life
and I'm starting my second act a third
act I was married once before and Bobby
and now Gary and I'm very happy and I
have a brand that I'm building it takes
an enormous amount of energy and time of
traveling all the time I have my rug
line and now I've got you know bedding
and towels and and draperies and you
can't imagine xx and pet I'm doing the
whole pet bossy line okay
exciting so I have twenty seven
categories coming out in 2020 I'm really
busy so I don't even you know I can't
imagine taking any more on I love going
back on the show that all my
girlfriend's I love them all and I want
to go back once a year or twice a year
whatever it is and just pop in let them
know I'm still alive say hi to my fans
and we do you ever have FOMO or a little
bit of jealousy seeing LuAnn and Ramona
sticking around this whole time on the
ride no no you know no no because you
know listen
it's you getting you give being on the
show there's a lot of things you get and
there's a lot of things you give up and
I think relationships was a sacrifice
that all women are all housewife shows
have made and the statistics show it so
I don't want that I got my guy and I'm
gonna keep them and I don't want to lose
them and I don't want the show to you
know put a wedge between us so I think
it's safe safe for me to just go in a
little and come back out toe in the
water it's okay because I love Bravo
it's you know where I grew up and as an
adult grew up and if it wasn't for them
I wouldn't have a brand and I wouldn't
have you know fans and it's great all
right not married yet but are we headed
toward marriage headed toward marriage
let's pick this way you should not be
surprised if we get married
but I think until you do something like
don't talk about it just do it it takes
away from ya so I'd rather not comment
on it but I'm happier than I've ever
been
I'm so fortunate to have met Jill when I
did and it's you know like I like to say
it's like saving the best for last we've
been married we have we have children
you know grown children lived a lot of
life seen a lot of things and sometimes
if you meet someone before you're really
ready it doesn't work it's kind of like
serendipitous that you want to meet the
right person very few people some people
meet the right person at the wrong time
but very few people meet the right
person at the right time and things just
work so that's where I am that's where
we were in a good place
sounds like you're enough very happy and
you'll have to watch and see what
happens
[Music]